hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
with John Humphrey oh yeah so one of our
number one people over at patreon is a
lovely lady named Rosa Parra Rosa Parra
is obsessed with this man over here
japanese god her daughter Cassandra
prefers me just so y'all know yes the
competition it's a competition but her
daughter Cassandra prefers named Rosa
has been one of our highest pledges
we've ever had on patreon and she's a
loyal commentator she's a loyal
subscriber and we found out she only
lives like a little less than an hour
away from us so we were like you know
what one of the reward tiers on our
patreon is that if you pledge a certain
amount you'll get one of our shirts and
we'll autograph it for you and we
thought since she's the first person to
pledge a certain amount where you would
receive an autographed shirt that we
would do something special for our first
timer to get this one we would
personally deliver it to her as Jon
struggles to find parking
yeah because Rosa lives in a very
dangerous neighborhood this is not the
place where John and I belong we don't
live here it's like Malibu's Most Wanted
in here were like Taye Diggs and Anthony
Anderson up in this [ __ ] terrifying
place the actors man was actor you can't
trust a dentist place next to a nail
salon so since she loves John so much
she asked if she could have a specific
shirt that we don't actually sell people
over at Collider put together a shirt
for John when he became MVP at the
showdown free-for-all and she asked if
she could have this design so we signed
it here to Rosa you're the MVP and our
hearts love John Humphrey and I said to
Rosa you will one day prefer me over
John Greg Allen whoo all right let's do
this it's good that there's a half a
shadow showing I have an inner conflict
about having to walk to this goddamn
neighborhood right now are you nervous
John so nervous keep your voices down
you're white pooping right now
this is Rose's family right here
hey Becca Sondra and I could Sondra
become a beginner he gets her along
mm-hmm
we have to get Cassandra hug birthday
recently you got to get a traditional
Greg alpha present $1 dish yep an annual
to ride album president given me a
dollar on multiple proven apparently
today we are so she had no idea we were
coming right now okay we don't ever lie
we don't lie no no D our house the para
near here Little John go give her her
present we got a California Pizza
Kitchen delivery port from B conferences
not anywhere not can you hold it a can
you pull it out to the to the crack we
have to we make people on come from ham
there is the exclusive one officer plan
[Music]
[Laughter]
John give the hug in there get that hog
[Music]
like a really low stakes version to
make-a-wish Foundation now via hey all
three of you come with your guys join
the frame are you good all targets
driver all para this is the first time
we've ever surprised anyone in our life
for any and every prize not surprise
birthday surprise numbers yeah so we're
happy to be here with you Rosa can I get
a hug too
oh yeah record the hug
[Applause]
[Music]